[Musique]
je vous suis sans doute inconnu quand
j'habitais ici jadis c'était il ya 400
ans on me nommait catherine du puy du
fou
les lions ont bien changé depuis et je
reviens sur un soir faire cette
promenade
j'aime bien regarder mon château de ce
côté là chaleur de ces briques le
rappelle mr italienne et quand le soleil
s'est couché
soudain gens pour ne pas des cheveux qui
traverse le temps descendant et
remontant le cours des âges eux aussi
les ont perdus leur siècle leurs courses
dans la nuit mais vite à la confusion
des époques et des à court de ma mémoire
en peuplant la demeure de toutes ces
ombres impalpable qui jour après jour il
se succédant dans l'histoire ont vécu
dans ce pays du bas poitou que je crois
vous appelez la vendée vous laisser à
chaque pro pour chara elles pourront va
pas mettre la petite car on va lui
mettre une grande plume un beau pelage
blanc quelque chose très très joli et
puis alors un bandeau blanc s'il faisait
partie d'un horrible on va le laisser en
dessous garnir le feront bientôt tout ça
c'est fini on va vérifier les stars tous
les galons dorés tout et vous permet
d'être en êtes vous je fais le mien
comment sol
terminé
[Musique]
à 60 km de nantes entre cholet et
pouzauges en plein coeur du haut bocage
vendéen rejoignons au pied de son
étrange château un homme qui sait
merveilleusement fait revivre au creux
de murat est lézardée par les siècles et
les guerres un souvenir impressionniste
du passé et du patrimoine de la vendée
avec un merveilleux don de soi même et
l'aide totale et bénévoles de toute la
population
diront ce que but environnantes philippe
de villiers lui même de souche vendéenne
avec une foi inébranlable elle sûre pour
une deuxième saison d'été consécutive le
succès de son spectacle d'art et
d'histoire
intitulé ce soir là vendée l'originalité
du spectacle tient à ce que nous n'avons
pas cherché à raconter l'histoire du
château du puy du fou encore moins
d'histoire de ses propriétaires
successifs mais bien le contraire à
travers la toile de fond du château au
delà de la pièce d'eau de raconter
l'histoire du pays du puy du fou c'est à
dire d'une population et le territoire
et de la faire raconter par les gentils
2 nous a demandé de faire 1250 posthume
l'an dernier nous avons fait les plus
simples nous avons loué les autres et
cette année par contre nous avons fait
ce que nous avions joué l'an dernier et
avec une équipe de couturières et
ailleurs les avons réalisé depuis trois
mois et ça a vraiment très bien marché
et tout cela bénévolement et vous créer
ses costumes de quelle manière vous
consulter des livres vous avez des ouïes
consultant dédié par les tissus sont
achetés ne les donne ans après aux
couturières et août ailleurs que ces
dames font cela en dehors de leur
travail bit user de leur travail les
couturiers reviennent le soir tailler et
ensuite nous distribuons aux couturières
tu le font chez eux
cela permet des contacts très
intéressants pour tout le monde
le club de mickey herbretais du
troisième âge a accepté de fournir un
gros effort pour la confection des
costumes du spectacle son et lumière du
puy du fou
elles font cela parce que ce spectacle
les intéressent au plus haut point
je pense que la vérité historique de ce
spectacle aura été très sensible et
qu'elles ont perçu qu'il y avait là
quelque chose de infiniment intéressant
pour le troisième âge
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le roi excusez moi monsieur mais qu'est
ce qui se passe ici
ouais nous sommes au contraire le
passage pour les acteurs la deux qui
vont derrière les selles dans l'arrière
scène pour accueillir monsieur vous
participer au spectacle
oui mais qu'est ce que vous faites
françois 1er et voilà mon suppléant
contrairement à beaucoup de spectacle de
plein air qui font appel à des figurants
nous faisons appel à des acteurs
qu'ils accomplissent leur propre passé
car le spectacle gelé conçue à partir de
la tradition orale
donc il n'y a pas de distance entre
l'acteur et son rôle il n'y a pas de
personnage
fabriquer un bazooka comptait attaquer
le château on compte continuer notre
spectacle faire beaucoup mieux que
l'année précédente surtout c'est là
notre objectif cette année
ici se fabrique un mortier qui
interviendra au moment de la guerre du
repli des bleus lorsque les vents des
attaques en 1793
[Applaudissements]
cette année j'ai recruté nous sommes
quatorze artificiers alors ça va du
marchand de grains en passant par le les
bénisse on a même un arbitre régional de
basket
notre ami fournier et il y a
les ouvriers en chaussures il ya tout ce
grand bricoleur gay michel godet le jour
et négociant en tissus aux herbiers et
chaque soir l'été ils courent embrasé
son château avec des vraies flammes sur
roulettes est assurée avec des faux gars
de son invention le réalisme des trois
grandes guerres ayant ensanglanté
l'amendé
à quelques kilomètres plus loin au
village de chants bretons dans une
menuiserie familiale une autre équipe
depuis follet bénévoles participent
activement pendant ses heures de loisirs
ou perfectionnement du spectacle du
puy-du-fou el attaf ou pas l'eau ils
doivent essieux ne sommes en vendée en
1979 joue un blanc et un bleu qu'est ce
que vous faites là là on fait les fusils
c'est philippe de villiers un soir de
répétition qui nous avait avec des
fusils qui peut être pas nous a
simplement dit chambretaud vous fassiez
les fusils qui pète alors on s'est mis
tous ensemble toute l'équipe de chants
bretons et on a fabriqué des fusils
effectivement maintenant qu'ils pètent
monsieur herriot en général dans un
atelier de menuiserie ont tout du bois
met en jeu la première fois je vois si
et du plexiglas et qu'est ce que c'est
que ce truc ce truc est bien vu où je
travaille à la réalisation d'un pass vue
circulaire qui équipera un appareil de
projection géante venant de d'autriche
et qui servira projeté sur le château
sur l'ensemble du château des
projections géantes
[Musique]
est ce que ça représente le puy du fou
pour vous à pour nous tracé difficile a
raconté il d'abord on n'y croyait pour
et puis on a tombé avec une ambiance
formidable maintenant que on attend que
ça on attend que ça revienne il y a
quatre villages d'acteurs qui regroupe
même des groupes appartenant à des
communes et il y à véritablement un
esprit de village c'est à dire à
l'esprit de clocher au niveau des
villages d'acteurs au niveau de la
taille
une idée il ya une émulation qui qui
intervient y compris dans les batailles
lorsque les bleus de chants bretons ou
de saint-laurent-sur-sèvre combattent
les vendéens de beaurepaire ou des
epesses vous changez vous prenez le
prochain habib tout simplement la
prochaine tenue pour la scène que vous
avez un âge où est le point de départ
cet automne à des projecteurs préparez
vous les gars monsieur sabiron ça se
tient comme en un village
ma foi pas trop mal les autres
professions chagny matters éducateur
dans un collège
et là on m'a demandé un jour de d'être
coordinateur de mise en scène pour le
spectacle où j'ai dit oui tout de suite
parce que j'aime la vendée j'aime le
théâtre j'aime le spectacle et puis
quand je me suis vu en face de 150
acteurs comme sage débutants qui
venaient avec leur bonne foi
je suis bon bah on va voir ce qu'on va
pouvoir faire c'était pas facile au
départ mais tout le monde en veut tout
le monde est et comment dire
mm ça et puis
c'est bon le contact du maïs en national
je dirais que le contact humain c'est la
plus belle réussite du spectacle
encore mieux que le spectacle pour ce
qui concerne l'organisation du spectacle
qui a toute une structure permettant
d'éviter qu'il y ait tant manquant à un
moment quelconque gamme i saw clip de la
direction alain stick fait fonctionner
jeter élèves de 2de chance à brice qui
est venu donner un coup de main tous les
coordinateurs de byzance had ça tourne
normalement et ça peut tourner comme ça
pendant des années je crois que ce qui
fait aussi la force du spectacle c'est
son esprit
bâtie sur la tradition orale et
s'exprimant à travers l'expression
locale
le spectacle du puy-du-fou repose
entièrement sur le don de soi c'est
peut-être là un nouveau gérant
d'expression combien de spectateurs
attendez-vous stone et et bien kutei
l'année dernière nous avons fait à peu
près 80 2500 entrées cette année nous en
attendons plus de 100 milles à l'heure
se voir comment vous avez la possibilité
de les recevoir
ah oui oui oui on a tout ce qu'il faut
pour cela c'est dire que la dernière
c'est une aventure un petit peu pour
nous on ne savait pas trop où on allait
avec le succès nous avons tout tenté
cette année pour que les conditions qui
étaient parfois difficiles l'année
dernière soit très sensiblement
améliorer la mémoire 2 avant de
commencer à baisser l'autre 70 à 80% de
façon ce n'est pas de variants
d'éclairage
si tu entends le soir
de la chouette on est
[Musique]
après
tonton
[Musique]
ton qui démangent
chez les rats
si tu entends souvent les quinze jours
moi je
non
des jeux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]